we're gonna look at some of your film
and we're gonna see what is said about
them and then you try and guess which
one is a fat irresistible Twinkie of a
summer thriller I like that you're more
concerned about summer Thriller just
totally glazing over a fat irresistible
Twinkle Twinkle all the time okay it's
messy and personal and real and that's
exactly what makes it great I mean I
feel like this is like every movie ever
it is like it's sloppy personal 12 train
wreck honestly I had a decent time
[Laughter]
that's his man bodyguard
apparently the body count is so high the
only thing missing is in the thermal hit
me a bodyguard nope Kingsman the Secret
Service oh I guess it did yeah watching
it is something like watching a gangly
baby deers initial efforts to stand
where its effort that's more engaging
than the actual achievement what about
me personally or about the film itself
about the film itself I'm thinking it's
the effort that's more engaging than the
achievement I mean honestly I'm gonna go
with the immigrant story it's the rice
movie interesting make no mistake this
movie is trash but it's meant to be and
I'd be lying if I said it wasn't also a
lot of
no it's just a bit positive it says that
the movies trash oh but then it says
well that's wrong like if McDonald's did
an American version of kimchi and served
us ketchup on cabbage a film that not
only knows it's a remake but knows how
absurd it has to be to succeed as a
remake clue janky clues the too easy for
her once you get a puppy
give me that puppy so I get bragging
rights now
[Music]